I didn't know that this is what this
country has to offer. It's uh I would
say so far of all the countries I've
been to, the most beautiful country is
Switzerland. Yeah. In terms of
topography and terrain, but now Colombia
I think is I have to see a little bit
more of it and decide maybe Colombia is
up there to be honest because the the
stuff that we were seeing there, you
would agree is really beautiful, isn't
it? Picturesque. Amazing. The weather is
amazing.
>> Yeah. Let's see. Let's see. We'll
document it.
>> See you at the top of the show.
Oh my gosh.
>> So, we just got into an altercation.
[laughter]
>> What happened here?
>> Now, what happened was this guy over
here, he stole something. Yeah. Can you
see the police?
>> There's another guy come beat him up.
>> Yeah. And uh we tried to get involved
with him to stop the beating up from
happening. Then what did he do? You tell
me.
>> He's pocket. [laughter] He had something
there.
>> You know, I thought, "Okay, well, hold
on. I'm not going to be a hero here in
[laughter]
teaching some moves.
>> Stand here. So remember the most basic
step is take your left leg, put it here,
do like this with your knee and then
change and change and then you start
like this with your hand and then move a
little bit the shoulder.
Yes. Yes.
Is it a contradiction? Why is it wrong?
How can we disprove
that Jesus
and the father, they call him the
father, we not call him the father, that
they are, they cannot both be God.
>> Yeah. Where we at now
rock. It's a big rock. Look, as you can
see, it's a good workout going up there.
Well, look, there's a guy here with a
with a with a thing. So, be careful.
>> Got to be careful.
>> The guy with a helmet. You know, they
say that if he's got a helmet that he's
going to commit a crime, isn't it? I'm
here for the main man Abdullah. The top
of the Gautapo. Is it Gautapo? Yeah.
>> Gotaape rock. This is a rock with I
don't know how many steps. About 700 and
something steps. It was a good workout
coming up. It's a bit like Jabal and
would you say?
>> Yeah. Very
>> very kind of seem
>> harder. But a lot harder.
>> You think it's harder? It's steeper,
isn't it? Get steeper.
>> But look at the beautiful view. Check it
out.
>> Amazing.
>> There's a lesson in this. The harder the
con, the more beautiful the view.
>> Absolutely.
>> I've been doing this since I was 17.
>> Okay. And I'm 34. So, basically what I
put is I put certain categories on top
here that I feel feel like I need to
work on in the next say 6 months or 12
months. Yeah.
and [music] and then I'll track to see
how productive I am on each of them.
>> It's beautiful, man. Mashallah. It's
nice weather. As you can see, there's
like lots of different things here, but
see, you got the pebbles. U Pebble Beach
isn't as good as this. The quality of
the pebbles are actually quite nice.
Then you've got all these hills here at
the top and you got the city life. No,
it's it's a beautiful thing. You know,
when you put all these things together,
you're not going to find this in UK,
right? So these are the kinds of things
you have to download. You have to get
out.
>> Guys, we're here outside of Nor
al-Islam. Can you see that? Let's just
look at Islam. We're here in Peru in
Lima, the capital of Peru. And we've,
alhamdulillah, I've been having a
beautiful time with this holiday. Let's
call it that. That's what it is. But at
the same time, we have to do a bit of da
as well. Can't forget. And to be honest,
this is fertile ground. So what we do
here is we go to the people that like
the imams and so on. We train them so
that they can in their local language do
da to the population and especially the
new Muslims.
>> I'm with who is Peruvian. He's actually
from Peru and he is an imam in this uh
masjid. I want to ask him a couple of
questions.
So I asked him about the Dao and how it
kind of developed and he said that in
the beginning when he was a kid there's
only one masjid in the whole of Peru.
Now there's like three masids in Lima
which is the capital city and there's
other masjids uh in other parts of Peru
and he's saying there's increasing
proliferation of da and I asked him what
are what's the demographics of people
that are Muslim in in Peru he said that
Muslim are actually uh converts to Islam
they are converts from Peru itself
they're Peruvian and they and there are
some people before they used to be
Palestinians and some Egyptians and some
Moroccans and stuff etc. But he said now
it's majority of that.
>> There's only 65 Muslims in this place
according to the imam.
>> Yeah.
>> And our theme for the last I don't know
couple of years you've seen you've seen
us go to Estonia. You've seen us go to
the Baltic countries like Lithuania and
Latvia where there's a 0.01%
population of Muslims. So we're here in
a place where there's 65 Muslims in the
entire city. Right. And because it's not
just it's all well and good going to big
crowds and getting the dopamine rush of
that but really it's important also to
go to the communities that need it the
best. Give them the tools connect them
with the resources and I think this is
the da fertile ground for da fertile
fertile ground for da and um inshallah
we'll be coming back to be honest.
It's a human bond.
>> This is a sacrifice for you visit.
[laughter]
>> The human sacrifice.
>> Yes.
>> This is this is all the local democracy
possible and any sacrifice
from long time ago or from recent ones.
>> She can't say she can't say
>> one [clears throat] made that sacrifice
[laughter] of him.
>> Possible.
You want to make a T already that
Too Faced, man. What you got on?
>> I don't know. But [laughter] I like it.
This is the Inca. To be honest with you
guys, I'll be honest. Like in terms of
clothes,
>> I love these kinds of clothes. You might
have you might have seen some of my
Mexican ones before,
>> but these ones are nice, man. They they
just got vibrance, you know? They've got
and they do they fulfill a function. You
know what I'm trying to say?
>> So, we're at the old match of Peach
City, as you can see.
Absolutely stunning, beautiful,
beautiful, amazing like as I said it's
must be one of the most if not the most
beautiful country I ever visited and
it's uh phenomenally phenomenal
mountains here
kind of fused you these little shops and
stuff like that. It's amazing.
So if we look at the seven wonders of
the world, I think there are different
lists depending on who you consult,
right? But usually in that list is like
pyramids in Giza, you've got the Great
Wall of China, you've got um obviously
Machu Picchu here. They've also got a
couple of other things. I I think this
one in terms of the natural landscape,
Yeah. is probably the best one. Yeah. In
terms of where it's embedded, it's
embedded in like these mountains. And in
terms of the aesthetics of it, how it
looks, this is probably the best looking
one aesthetically. But yeah, definitely
it's up there and it's a beautiful place
to come and it's one of the most amazing
and spectacular spectacular sites I've
ever seen in my entire life. So hello
for being articulate, for engaging in a
lot of interface discussions and for
having a pretty confident and bold
style. And I can certainly say that a
lot of people appreciate his passion and
the way he stands up for what he
believes in. So if he's someone you
really look up to, that made perfect
sense. I'm glad you're liking it. So
just to add a bit more, [laughter]
MUHAMMAD HIJAB [screaming]